welcome back everybody to 2038 that's
the future we're here for one simple
reason
what was it again talked to a man to
everybody Amanda now I don't mean to
judge a man but okay I'm not that kind
of guy you know why I realized this is
bad
better if I don't talk he's gonna call
her okay that's all I was gonna do there
she is look at that a little creeper oh
she sucks you suck Amanda your freaky
person after what happened today the
country is on the verge of a civil war
the machines are rising up against their
masters humans have no choice but to
destroy them what about fine temps can
do something
I was wrong maybe he did but you chose
not to ask see staying silent
what is his Kamsky designed this place
created the first version it's been
improved significantly since then why do
you ask
I saw a photo of Amanda cam skis place
oh she was his teacher when cam ski
designed me he wanted an interface that
would look familiar
that's why he chose his former mentor
what are you getting it you didn't tell
me everything you know about deviance
did you find answers Connor not ask
questions you're the only one who can
prevent Civil War find the deviance or
there will be chaos this is your last
chance Connor bejing but young Connor
where's the thongs why did I say that
great everybody
uncover the bag what but we're onto
something but we just need more time I'm
sure thank you don't get it
this isn't just another investigation
it's a [ __ ] civil war it's out of our
hands now we're talking about national
security here [ __ ] that you can't just
pull the plug now not when we're so
close you're always saying you can't
stand Androids Jesus Hank make up your
mind hey not to crack the case I know we
can solve it oh my god hey Jeffrey can't
you back me up this one time Hanks voice
is dumb isn't mr. crash nothing I can do
you're back on homicide I just heard it
returns to cyber life I'm sorry Hank but
it's over from Sponge Bob Squarepants
oh my god I I saw the comments about it
but it never connected until now
it's literally him is that how it looks
like
sumimasen so you never very much
[Music]
let's talk to Hank Kuehne all right
let's make sure we don't mess is that
all right so you love me right in case I
mess up this okay I played it I play
this scene because I got it wrong
okay we need more time we could have
solved this case we just needed more
time so you're going back to cyber life
I have no choice
I'll be deactivated and analyzed to find
out why I failed
what if we're on the wrong side yeah
what if we're fighting against people
who just want to be free
defective regrets regrets yes deviance
fries up there will be chaos we could
have stopped it now it's too late there
must be the secret we with RF used to
give a nine year Android at camp skis
place you put yourself in her shoes you
showed them to think honor
empathy is a human emotion
I don't know why I did it uh-oh
[Music]
I'm not programmed to say things like
this hey change subject we're best
friends right with you yeah haha a
little more time who knows
what if you become friends or lovers
that's right I ship it here comes
burgers that [ __ ] sure don't
waste any time at the FBI we can't give
up I know the answers and the evidence
we collected if Perkins takes it it's
all over there's no choice you heard
Fowler we're off the case
you've got to help me with that I need
more time so I can find a lead in the
evidence we collected I know the
solution is in there
listen Connor if I don't solve this case
cyber life will destroy me five minutes
that's all I ask
he's gonna become a DB ain't he - the
basement is on my desk get a move on I
can't distract him forever oh you take
the key from Hanks desk why we have five
minutes to do that
all right you know what fair enough now
what hurry to the archive room all right
listen up
whoa punch he's speeding she just
doesn't care anymore
what a legend thank you hence a summer
mom what a guy I'm talking to you
[ __ ]
where you going wouldn't need a plastic
bye hey hey we gotta hurry
[Music]
so this is the evidence server now why
just used to key here okay man is so
cool
[Music]
all right let's use the evidence panel
by clicking on it with our mouse
big-titty kauai district 420 blaze it
[ __ ] password that's good
that was the easiest puzzle of the game
hey look at solar evidence that we all
look Alexis sure ok so oh no I don't
think we got it high but I think we got
enough evidence gotta think fast gotta
go fast everybody
[Music]
Jericho it's a boat well let's get all
that r9k evidence wait so it's not it
[Music]
but it is also a warning we will fight
for our rights because I don't think
there's anyone here just no human will
live in peace until we are free now you
know who we are mobile board we are
alive and we demand our freedom okay
you're talking too much can I put it
this way
Oh what what oh it was us thinking it's
not alike Markus the deviant leader
speech is a clue okay we got our
lectures okay that's another clue okay
okay triggers inside I think you can
back up here and we'll examine more over
here yes there's a lot of things to
examine here
[Music]
Oh
why it's happening I don't have that
thing so I can't use it no that sucks so
I don't have enough yeah but I don't
have is needed for reactivation what
does that mean see I got all of them
except one oh I can still analyze okay
oh okay okay wait I'm an idiot I'm an
idiot I can only talk about my the one
that's a 3 9 2 3 9 3 9 is that what I
said two three nine eight I am I must be
a genius
honestly I don't think anyone has ever
solved this possible before oh that's
not the one no it is okay thank God all
right there you go you're welcome all
right talk to me baby talk
where your day you're dead mine I need
to find Jericho tell me how to get there
don't recognize your voice you're not
one of us I'll never tell you what
Jericho is great now leave me alone
good job Phillips try to trick him what
if I talk to him because he's a deviant
right
what is his speech maybe this is speech
I don't know
[Music]
so anything else I can't do anything on
him now no anymore okay apparently I
can't interact with the items because I
have one in my hand so I should be able
to interact here and use the leader
maybe
Paula shouldn't use himself sample voice
[Music]
hey you can just copy voices yeah it's
me your own brain Marcus remember
everything is alright don't worry yes
yeah I tried to reach you but even on
just stop yeah cuz you fail you stopped
him from finding me you saved me
you saved Jericho you'll be alright now
I came to take you home give me the
location to Jericho wait you don't know
the location you know it yes I do the
leader of Jericho what a dumb schmuck
fell for the oldest trick in the book
yeah yeah it's your ex oh I shipped them
I shipped them I definitely shipped them
now I've been dreaming about this since
the first second I saw you you have
weird dreams dude don't do it Gavin I
know how to stop the deviance you're off
the case and now it's gonna be
definitive
it's Conner Tam that's right oh my god I
got shot what just happened to me
okay relax no one knows how to make them
know number one in the game
[Music]
okay well that could have gone better
no okay Oh Connor you better hurry
[Music]
whoa I guess there was a lot of evidence
you could go through and as you can see
here we got the get the result on the
bottom which means we got the best
result which means is that we win at
life everybody congratulations how does
that feel
cool
just realize I published a video by
accident I'm a good youtuber alright
it's called multitask and get on my
lover
I love the carrot parts so good I love
it so good
love the carrot parts so good they're
bonding strangely all right I'm Your
Mother
okay don't listen at ucky took her
Betty's room can Chucky guess his name
it's a big directing raids all over the
city
whoa yesterday
it's gonna be alright
we're almost there if they hate Android
so much why did they create them I don't
get it universe doesn't make sense to me
sometimes this place um just by c2 I
like sad it's not this is not turn it
off is grinding to a halt hospitals and
schools are closing water cuts blackouts
failures are expected maybe most
worrying of all our armed forces have
lost two-thirds of
how about some music instead
why are the seats like this if Jess
Macedo is playing
really looks like a Japanese car in
Japan they all have really squared cards
they look like cubes it's really cute
I'm not gonna help you
it's really awkward this game is if you
don't make any movements here we go okay
the game literally forces you Alice is
like what what's wrong would be a little
further on that way there's a large
freighter called Jericho when you get
there find Marcus he will help you the
last bus for the border leaves at
midnight you absolutely have to be on it
you'll be safer on the other side we
sure picked a good timing oh my god
but it's a start my brother lives in
Ontario I've given you his address he'll
be able to hide you until things calm
down you know it's the very brave little
girl Alice you deserve to be happy
thank you for everything
let me know when you make it over there
all right
[Music]
and be careful
take care of them
[Music]
ball girls did I hang around you know
I'm glad we having a mars-sized to catch
yeah let's go
[Music]
Jericho sorry everyone
I was first with me
oops
I am not very smart
ducks restaurant yeah I want to go there
makes me hungry Oh Connor Connor I
didn't even recognize you oh my oh
you're gonna do that come on we've done
this don't make me do this again
so once he founds Jericho were like
what's the next move for Connor
oh we're gonna meet up at the same time
[Music]
you think that vote is still functioning
you don't have to be so mean about it on
your screen and the authorities will
come to collect your can joy
is there no opposing opinion from the
human side and saying like you know what
maybe we should listen this must be
according to some sources the Russian
forces also seem mysteriously to have
withdrawn the Kremlin has made no
comment for the moment but it is quite
possible that the Russian army has been
confronted with a similar crisis oh cool
find a warm place for a holiday listen
she doesn't even look : hey got sick
Sepp you schmuck I don't like your
elements I never liked you
how do you feel hot suit I guess you got
a fever
stay with her I'll try to find this
Marcus the last buses in two hours and
the terminals on the other side of town
we haven't got much time we'll leave as
soon as we have passports Karen there's
something I have to tell you it's about
Alice we'll have lots of time to talk on
the bus I'll be back
stay with Alice
I think I know what he's getting at but
I don't want to spoil it because I read
some comments I first thought it was too
dumb but it's really getting that at
least
Oh what we're at Connor I don't even
realize where's Marky move
where's markiplier huh
really good framerate here
you're looking for yourself
tip good good one
oh my DVD anyone from any harm that
comes just it was sheer carnage they're
Androids over the square hello I'm back
it's not better cool I'm glad I start
these videos when it's loading
professional youtuber here I could just
edit it asked why Lisa why I love you
Lisa you might tell you my everything
you betray me
hello hi Marcus
I'm with a little girl and another
Android there's a bus leaving for the
border in less than two hours and we
need passports no Detroit's under curfew
they're soldiers everywhere they're
rounding up all the androids and sending
them to camps maybe you should stay here
while
maybe right you might be safer here
until things calm down one of our people
used to work in the State Department
he has electronic passports you can
easily modify
I'll have him get them to you
we said you with a little girl right
you know that humans hate us are you
protecting her
I don't care whether she's human or
Android
she's just someone who matters to me
tell me don't worry
but it's fake news ya actin come on
Alice
okay is this where we are oh she's an
Android oh my yeah
then YK 500 the perfect child well if
she's so perfect then why is she so
annoying it tried telling you you knew
from the beginning yeah she didn't eat
the spaghetti and she wanted a walk and
you wanted someone who careful
[Music]
what difference does it make
it makes sense that the model original
takács without the shadows
Alice loves you Carol she loves you more
than anything in the world her she
became the little girl you wanted and
you became the mother she needed wait so
she faked having a fever she faked being
cold she's a faker daters and you know
what we do with Baker Baker
which mash it's not hard Alice let's
just send her off to some foreign island
I think that's the only thing to do like
we'll send her off someplace real bad
like Canada yeah let's take it a Canada
that'll be an epic troll all right where
is this lush musk we'll play along we'll
play along like we don't know no where
is she
Alice your [ __ ] you you Lotte
looking son of us you betray me you
betray me Alice no why honestly I don't
remember why I left her this is so
annoying
she's right there Felix I oh okay she's
right there
you I don't need attitude every single
episode saying I don't see obvious
things okay
these are unedited videos and you're
just gonna have to deal with me
began tuck
what up Alice dab-dab on her you done
goofed me Alice you're not even cold
didn't even in a sweater you didn't even
poop do you
she doesn't even Pope hey fine you know
what fine we'll play along hey you know
what
[Music]
forever I'm so glad this I'm come king
if marca comes in and says execute order
66 and get them banished that would be
great
Luther is part of it sorry Luther you
weren't invited you're not part of our
family Luther don't just invite yourself
sheesh
[Music]
we're short on blue blood and bio
components are wounded or shutting down
and there's nothing we can do
reservoir and a similar threat to
national security and we need to be
exterminated
humans are conducting raids and all the
big cities and they're taking androids
to camps to destroy them it's a disaster
they're slaughtering our people it's all
our fault
none of this wait for the Americans to
come back white oh wait oh that side our
kin than that man okay so let's just be
right you couldn't just suffer in
silence they're killing us nothing is
gonna justify that your television
speech it sounded like a declaration of
war violence only leads to more violence
you reap what you sow Simon I thought
you were the only one on my team okay
all right no regrets
humans enslaved us I'll never regret
standing up to that we shouldn't forget
who our enemies are can't fight amongst
ourselves
he's right all that matters now is what
we do next
[Music]
Marcus dialogue is the only way north I
don't care I will go alone as long as
Simon my man try to talk to them one
last time
don't do this Marcus they'll kill you
maybe
I know if I have to try if I don't come
back lay low as long as you can
come on come on you love me just come
back no that's it you better go you
better need to realize how much they're
hurting us find the right words and
they'll listen sometimes you know my mom
and I when she was yeah when I was
younger she wouldn't tell me if you
don't know how to express yourself you
should just sing a song Alexis
they've been butchering each other for
centuries over the color of their skin
or whatever god they wanted to worship
they're not gonna change violence is
just in their genes how profound they
can't stop what we've started
since you've been here you've given us
hope you've given me hope today a
deviant arrived in Jericho and he told
me that he stole a truck transporting
radioactive cobalt
he said that he abandoned the truck
somewhere in Detroit and ready to
explode
I convinced him not to do it to give me
the detonator
I'm dirty ball we can't lose this war
Marcus
if humans overcome us our people will
disappear forever this may be our only
chance to survive if things go wrong I
shouldn't become like down north we can
gain our freedom by other means
I hope you're right
whatever happens tomorrow oh hello I
just want you to know that it's time
it's time come on want to dream
come on Quantic Dream don't let me down
it's time she's cold Oh Marcus I thought
you loved that old man Marcus
but I was wrong oh no they have avatars
sex and for God
how could you and the others oh my god
that was it Quantic drink you're busting
my nuts
look after yourself my robotic bing
balls well then you shouldn't have left
why did you leave me
it's gonna cry she's gonna detonate
Connor Connors wearing a beanie
Connors wearing a beanie God's done
Connor thank you
you've succeeded in locating Jericho and
finding their leader no problem now deal
with Marcus I ride I ride armed alive
okay
the very peaceful leader yeah let's stop
him kick
I know the game really wants you to
stray off a bad path like make Marcus
start a revolution but I won't hesitate
to shoot if you give me no choice what
are you doing
you are one of us you can't betray your
own people uh uh you're coming with me I
know you hit me hit him with an O you're
Connor aren't you yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah but he's wearing a beanie though
it's hard to recognize hunter well
congratulations you seem to have found
what you were looking for
you're nothing to them you're just a
tool they used to do their dirty where a
mom break free Connor had more than that
we're all more than that listen to the
nine year olds Connor sow doubt question
have you never wondered who you really
are
whether you're just a machine and
executing a program or living being came
on Connor take off the bein a I think
the time has come for you to ask
yourself that question but see those
curls Connor
what does undermine me I don't know
buddy you never have any doubts not in
this context you've never done something
irrational as if there's something
inside you something more than your
program I kind of do something now it
means it's time to decide yeah thank you
hey yeah right I'm a deviant Marcus
that's all they took they just had to
meet Marcus you know what that guy's
awesome you know there's no one
pressuring Connor right now peace is
there you know what I'm sick of this
we're pros now you didn't even have to
touch me a man that betrayed screw you a
man there pepopepa
going to attack Jericho what
[Music]
thanks for the warning really appreciate
hitch
oh no don't bother me when I listen in
there joke yeah quick we've gotta get
out of here
phantom governments enemies oh no don't
get Tucker no no no no if Tucker dies
I'm gonna do this it's like my favorite
character just know so much about him
come on Tucker keep running no I feel
like Tucker's the kind of guy that will
die to save me I don't like this full-on
sample you know what if there's a choice
I'm not saying I wanna make fun but if
there's a choice between Tucker and
Tucker they're coming from all flights
are paperless trapped in the hold
they're gonna be slaughtered I need to
have a message their exits on the second
and third floor find them and jump in
the river
[Music]
but who's Simon and Josh well separated
coming from the upper deck now two will
be caught in a crossfire we have to run
Marcus there's nothing we can do all
right let me think here so let's what
should we do I think we should blow out
Jericho the ship goes down they'll
evacuate now people can escape we'll
never make it
the explosives are all the way down in
the hold there are soldiers everywhere
she's right
the know who you are they'll do anything
to get you you had to be no Khan he'll
join you later Marcus I won't be long
you know you can wear loose fitted
clothes
isn't being a deviant much better
[Music]
I don't care don't care bye this is the
end of Jericho crime or save our people
Marcus
thank God you didn't drag it out okay
let's
what markets become this badass the
chosen one just like Fahrenheit in the
end of Fahrenheit
where'd the game just becomes the matrix
not I want that to happen to this game
save yourself no Tucker carrot a sweater
Gary help Eleuthera would care talker
how is she carrying that giant man
you should have done that yeah she
should have moved I agree that listen
danger go now before they come back you
what are you going to do I manage Alice
is all that matters
[Music]
I ain't leaving Luther Luther can't do
the board okay go now take care of each
other
[Music]
no this is bogus I'm going back
so close but so far all right don't
worry about me okay
you just got 6x you just got 6x that's
how they miss you in video
okay sure
crazy many things there are n happen I
was honestly knocking over that was I am
you know I counter curious what will
happen good thing he wore the helmet
close the door you loser do something
[Music]
get his weapon
are they blind
[Music]
it's Marcos time Oh
oh look it back he's angry
Bing Bing Bing Bing Bing Bing Bing Bing
bong Bing Bing bong
[Music]
intervene here at the people see he can
take down to military maybe go now
hurry Marcus I'm up go what are you
doing my guys
Bing Bing Bing Bing bong
bing-bong bing-bong
damnit one out gurgles
okay so
it's stopped
[Music]
can I stop them
Alexa
oh we got ink
that's my boy
that's right doesn't matter if he makes
it this way by North I'll join you later
oh that's Josh who's Simon
too many characters I'm sorry
whilst moving
cool
[Music]
he's sweating come on let's get out of
here
I would have just popped one in their
heads not that I would do it but I'm
just saying I would have just done it
you know what I mean I'm not saying I
would do it's difficult quick we've
gotta go
why does everything have to be so hard
with you guys he doesn't even remember
Sam and of course I remember Simon are
you kidding me he's the best
okay join the augur legitimately curious
how the hell did that as Marcus been
studying up with a martial arts there
like what happened I like it this is
what I want it yes yes keep the gun
keep the gun just keep the gun five
minutes
[Music]
look bones gonna explode any second we
got to get out of here
so now you're like good Marthe north
Jericho like that
Simon mom man I love Simon he's the best
have I told her by Simon my favorite
game it's true like Mars there's nothing
we can do for her we've got a run you
know what he makes a compelling case I
think I think we got
yeah holy heck yeah okay what's
ridiculous yes those helmets are full
over there oh my god
Connor
yes what are you doing oh god no no no
this can't be the end of Connor I refuse
I'm so vitamin r1 and r2 I was like damn
Connor got moves son
yeah don't shoot back right quick come
on that's got to be cold
black rats and amazed but who's the ramp
they said needed explosive in the hole
the ship is sinking further than you
evacuate calling all units
abandon ship and evacuate immediately
Alexis Marcus that was fun I really
enjoy that
yeah how long have I gone do we have
time for another I worried that there's
like one more episode left and then if I
play more it will be like a really short
last episode so let me just give me one
second I'm hacking here I'm gonna hack
the mainframe and I'm gonna try and
figure it out here let's see here oh my
god say something Simon I love Simon
Simon is the best dude honestly better
babe baby baby baby baby baby
[Music]
Frick it let's keep playing yes Thank
You Phoebe you are welcome
Oh are we back to the old mug dude I bet
you when he seizes I know I think I know
what reaction he's gonna give you think
I know how Carl is gonna react it's
gonna go oh this is so sad
can we play top five sad dispersity two
remixes what do you think he is at this
time probably drinking down and what are
you doing Marcus what I'm holding
forward
Carly
maybe he's in his studio it looks Li
the painting we drew that's the one I
drew cuz I had to replay that part so I
drew differently because I got bored
[Music]
okay well I suppose he's upstairs then
love these tiles very cool all right
Carl
it's a giant painting right there bad
mood
who are you how did you get in I need to
see Carl Carl isn't see anyone you need
to leave okay
attitude
please I need to see him you think it's
not gonna work
he's very weak okay I'm not sure you'll
be able to talk to you
oh my god no come on come on
save markers I was hoping you go I miss
you so much girl you don't know how much
I miss what's wrong it's kind of fine
isn't he
you taught me everything I know but I
wasn't prepared for this
I thought we would win because our cause
was just I realize just how wrong that
was world's ruled by fear Markus fear of
others fear the future it's like me too
old it's time for a damn
[Music]
well what should I do Carl they're
killing my people I don't want to answer
violence with violence but tell me what
choice do they give being alive is
making choices between love and hate
between holding out your hand or closing
it as a fist
I don't have any easy answers Marcus you
have to accept the world as it is or
fight to change it so he's telling us we
should fight with violence is that what
you mean man Fred you're my son Marcus
wanted Wawa Fred blood isn't the same
color but I know part of me is in you
[Music]
when the world falls in the darkness
some men have the courage to lead it out
one of those men
face the abyss but don't let it go
somewhere
[Music]
baby no okay all right hey no one asks
your opinion listen here you little
sauce let's roll
I'm not afraid to instigate violence
you're lucky this isn't cameras okay do
you understand me
I see the fear in your eyes
that's what I thought
[Music]
here's what I think
if
I'd like to believe that even though the
outcome isn't what you wanted if you
lead or follow actions in the cost that
you believe it's right it doesn't matter
what the outcome is does that make sense
I feel like maybe that's a bit of a dumb
statement I need to think about that
more I don't know I guess in games is
always about justice or whatever and all
these choices what's the most righteous
but I wanted to try and play this in a
way where I make the choices I believe
is right at least for the situation hey
North how's things down shot no okay
they say they don't want to take any
risks with deviance so they're rounding
our people up and taking them to the
camps for extermination
in a few hours we're gonna be the only
ones left
how many of us survived the attack
a few hundred maybe more if you count
those hiding all over the city
if you hadn't triggered the bomb we'd
all be dead
[Music]
what's your system status I'm okay damn
what's your system static well I didn't
hit any backup on it you could have been
killed trying to save me Marcus you have
to think of our people first nothing
else matters
in a few hours in a lobby over will have
changed the world of the world will have
destroyed us
you have to make a choice Marcus but
whatever you choose we will follow you I
love you Marcus
this is
[Music]
now look in front of other people huh
get a room guys please
[Music]
Hey look at these doofuses you
ding-dongs I thought you'd be safe
staying with us I was wrong
you need to leave the city while you
still can getting miles away from here's
all the matters now
we have to catch the last bus you might
still have a chance to cross the border
Marcus
save our people
god I like I didn't think I could
dislike Ally's even more good job
decide Connors fate Connor where is he
well we can talk to this guy you're
welcome
saved your life there didn't I
if it weren't for you I could
thanks to you I might see her people
free one day you and I haven't always
agreed but I know now we're fighting for
the same thing whatever you decide I'm
with you Marcus Oh Josh you're buttering
my bullets here
thank you good talk good talk Josh
was he gonna tell that to me even if I
didn't come up to him or all right sorry
Connor but the beam the beam is gonna go
it's my fault
I know the humans managed to locate
Jericho oh I was stupid
I shoulda guessed they were using me I
wonder how the game ends if we just
shoot Marcus I'm sorry Marcus I can
understand if you decide not to trust me
I'll be safe we're gonna trust you're
one of us now your place is with your
people there are thousands of androids
at the cyber life assembly plant if we
could wake them up they might join us
and shift the balance of power you want
to infiltrate the cyber life Tower and
Connor that's suicide new Connor was a
mad lion they trust me they'll let me in
if anyone has a chance of infiltrating
cyber life it's me if you go there they
will kill you there's a high probability
but statistically speaking there's
always a chance for unlikely events to
take place
be careful
yes okay okay
Quantic Dream what are you doing
doctor your people alright my people
where do I go to talk to my people I
want to talk to my man the legend the
myth sigh me sue me could you meet this
guy look at this guy
our people are counting on you Marcus
you're the only one who can lead us I
don't know give Alex are trying to go
we'll follow you my man my man I wonder
if the androids are made from real
people I know they are in obviously real
life but in the game are they modeled
from real people or are they just
recreated individually
all right so how do I do that like where
do I stand okay on the podium that makes
sense
humans have decided to exterminate us
yes I mean no our people are packed in
camps right now being destroyed they
should all tipos time has come to make a
choice one that very well may determine
the future of our people march
peacefully toward the camps to pressure
authorities launch an assault on the
camps to liberate the androids well I
know we are gonna do this we just put
that all Angry
and I know you want to fight back but I
assure you violence is not the answer
here we are going to tell them
peacefully that we want justice
Noren if there's any Humanity in them
they will listen and if not others will
take our place and continue this fight
yes are you ready to follow me
thief Pearlstein toasteen toasteen
toasteen post
yeah let's march peacefully okay Island
today's episode there hope you guys
enjoy tomorrow is going to be the last
one it's always sad to go say goodbye
but we are getting there everybody it's
been an interesting play through I'm
gonna I'm going to talk too much for now
I will see you then